27 wins in a row without a lock the
group just clicked and it looks like
they can thing together forever for
eliminating 12 and 0 better consider the
untouchable fastest win and North
American LCS history and
in the bakken and a huge smile
the first big thing let's touch on
immortals because this is kind of the
unknown team they're known players
unknown team this looks like a roster
that has a lot of stars on it most of
what we did to find the roster for
mortals was just watching a lot of game
footage I think when you really pay
attention you can really have a greater
idea of how people are actually
benefiting the team and that kind of
lets you put together a balanced roster
we also have to keep an eye on PO Beltre
and wild turtle that these are two guys
that have one LCS titles previously but
we're both released from their teams now
this is their chance to find redemption
on a new squad I think what's different
about the mortals is a I'm not afraid to
dish out criticism to my teammates
because I know that they can take it
before I would kind of have to worry
about whether my team is you're gonna
kind of take the blow kind of hard and
on immortals I feel really trusting and
all of my teammates to not take it too
personally one thing about morals that's
different is we have more of like a
family environment we're really close
together I think just by living together
and they're talking each other like
almost most of the days just like making
you really close we go out to eat korean
BBQ and like your karaoke we have some
really bubbly people on the team in wild
turtle and honey they're both really you
know they just walk into a room and they
want to be friends with you so we kind
of bonded pretty quickly yeah we like
stopping a lot to go out shopping or
like find commune clothes and spending
way the mortals are
take down cloud nine for their first
series of the summer split I think
overall like so much pit is like better
version of us inspirational it was
really newest roster for now everyone
was like God really used to getting
together because you're just to make
going into summer split and going into
playoffs i think we're not gonna
underestimate any more teams and play a
different place though if you place
first you directly qualified two worlds
and over all the points that you get for
each playoffs placing is higher than
last flip in addition best of threes in
regular split is also a big change with
this best of three format we're probably
gonna see more instances of immortals
being challenged go to them and this
immoral Steve they have so much
confidence in each other we as a team
are learning a lot from the
best-of-three format it allows us to try
stuff we really never would have tried
investable inform that invest of one you
use pick your most reliable that's the
chance of winning a singular game
strategy and that allows you to like not
try specific bans against the enemy team
or niche pics that you've been
practicing and you learn a lot less you
could have like a bad game and then you
would just lose for the day but now
we're able to come back and prove sweep
them so that's a really good feeling
what
there's too much feeling I strongly
believe that mortals has what it takes
to go to Worlds but we just have to work
for it I think we would do really well
we got there yeah yeah we're gonna just
try as much as we can but she'll
definitely try to reduce the number of
mistake we made I think having this in
mind who helps me I don't want to say
already that right off the bat we're
gonna go to Worlds because we kind of
said to the same thing last foot that we
were probably just gonna outright win
and we didn't win and it always kind of
sucks with the game four of us have been
the world's previously in the last year
so I think it's likely that we will